c'est ils ont droit les gaillards -
attendent d'eux si par hasard il avait
comme un songe guitare qui le rend les
élèves tous ses repas représente environ
2 5 % des collégiens
on cite quatre ou cinq poissons des
réunionnais et dix fois cent de ceux de
salazie avec nos élèves de segpa
notre travail consiste à leur redonner
confiance en eux par une équipe
d'enseignants investi à travers des
plateformes et de belles rencontres
d'abord lui a fait confiance parler quoi
les meilleurs une bienveillance un
accompagnement soutenu
[Musique]
la vie
les élèves de segpa font six à dix
semaines de stage antonin de troisième
et en cuisine
monsieur techer est entré dans la
pharmacie pour évaluer suite anna est
bien accompagné français d'accord jamais
d'absence
donc c'est pas pareil les relations avec
les collègues
comment ça s'est passé
très bien elle est très souriant 13
compagnies se sont voulu confier alors
tout ce qui était possible de lui faire
faire c'était
effectuer des commandes de médicaments
les parapharmacies connexes et toute
préparation
voir avec celle par quelqu'un demande
écuries du merchandising de la mise en
place de produire pour vous pensez que
c'est qu'une l'efs reims aujourd'hui
dans sept mois
tout à fait
jean professionnels le sérieux
je l'en de vias j'aime beaucoup cet
établissement
les gens sont très accueillants très
sympa j'apprécie la spontanéité des gens
d'ici des élèves du personnel
[Musique]
bonjour à tous vents finances adji en
fait
je
aujourd'hui on va continuer à travailler
sur les fonctions en mathématiques donc
qu'est-ce qu'une fonction samuel un
calcul qui va s'exprimer comment est
aujourd'hui l'exemple qu'on a choisi de
traiter ce soir dave dennis que ces
gars-là 4x très bien alors sultanat est
ce que tu peux me calculait f-22 gens en
place le x à l'étude ça fait 4 à des
très bien donc quatre fois deux galas et
ont terminé f25 qu'on va demander à
nicolas a notamment passé l'igf a donc
quatre fois cinq qui font elles
je demandais un univers où une élève de
venir leur présenter un tableau
allez steve année tu prends la règle et
le feu tu vois là aussi ce que nos tu
vas te passer
ça vaut
dirigé par bérengère aux molosses la 4e
prépare avec les parents un voyage
gastronomique ce mois de mai en
languedoc roussillon
accueillis au collège de sérignan ils
vivront de beaux moments rencontre de
pierre hermé spectacle au puy-du-fou
natation promenade en bateau etc
[Musique]
sultana conduit ses copines chez elle
ensemble elles se souviennent de tihange
lots a pris au collet mais si zolani et
rappelle à 3 ou non réussi
ça ça
je
c'est logique
maypray personnes dans son reer vous en
réjouir des zones basses qu'on saigne
boily bonheur son panier sans satané
bien lieu
tiens j'ai
nous sommes bien contents de l'eau
face au bayer dans l'ambassade turque
les boîtiers janvier
après le rythme scolaire soutenu nous
proposons d'écouter des personnes de
salazie et rural on a plus d'affinités
avec les gens je dirai plus quand on
connaît les familles de la grand-mère
aux petits-enfants et ça c'est une
bêtise et a forcé la bâtisse est pas
comme moi mes enfants maintenant les
bras y est j'ai 19 ans et je suis très
fier de cet enfant il ya c'est qu'à
l'école maternelle de beauport est à 8
on sait quoi être une femme monique du
proche des mamans ou le redécouvrir des
grossesses dans certains domaines de la
vie on est plus proche des femmes
longtemps à l'école il n'y avait pas
trop zh n'avait pas le dise mans et avec
des arbres à bois de pommes mais malcom
x toit amovible reste à l'ipo c'est un
grand plaisir
[Musique]
c'est le roi c'est avec des abus ce
qu'on venait de grimper de fleurs sont
fondues suis un déport robuste montée
flotte au niveau de leurs prêts de ses
arbres centenaires à le voit fleurir
on dirait un frère auprès de ses grands
frères
le benjamin de la forêt des singes ont
laissé nu à l'école dans les sentiers où
il est nommé labour nous pied dénommé
labour après la récolte est remis à
devoir vous drapez la de l'eau parfois
7200 et d'autres amis que l'on présente
à lui seul à 0
on peut trouver le jeu préféré
la 13è capuche ou la paille chopin des
bagues des bracelets des vrais des
pièces plus ma place et à leurs
harmonies donne aurait lieu j'habite à
salazie boycott à mare à poule d'eau
elle beau mal de place j'ai vu ferait
une serre quand j'étais petit mon jeu
préféré avec mes fraises a été défait la
poisse avec un robot jay de bâton je
devrai faire des câlins bon moment avec
un prix qui s'appelait les livres et je
l'emmenais souvent dans le parc du
colosse ou encore la paix n'est pas mise
je fais pas ci dessus comme ça les a
pour l'heure pas chose aisée des
spectacles des choses de la docilité à
2,6 j'aimerais intégrer la marine
pendant quatre ans est retraité accueil
j'aimerais à ce qu'il était au mondial
et des jo je voudrais faire mon gars
j'aime dessiner je me débrouille assez
bien ce que signifie préfet jean michel
très grand format mais si timide parce
que je n'aime pas me faire remarquer
qu'il aiderait aller plus loin dans mes
excuses pour avoir un beau travail il me
plaît j'ai vu à quel point le travail de
qualité été mise en place dans le
disciplinaire mais également dans
l'épanouissement de l'élève et ça c'est
une grande fierté pour un établissement
situé en éducation prioritaire et dans
un milieu rural isolé pour finir du tant
que foyer socio éducatif du collège
[Musique]
monde